première question donc gaulliste vous
avez dit gaulliste je vais vous
soumettre plusieurs noms si vous êtes
d'accord pour 2017
michèle alliot marie marine le pen
nicolas dupont aignan françois hollande
qui vient de se rendre à colombey les
deux églises
un premier une présidence socialiste à
faire ce déplacement sur la tombe du
général tous invoquent donc les mânes de
de gaulle est ce qu'il ya dans la liste
dans le lot la des usurpateurs selon
vous ce que chacun chacun reconnaîtra il
y adeux de sincère ou non d'incongru ou
non dans la référence des uns et des
autres ou au gaullisme que le président
de la république aille se recueillir sur
la tombe du du général de gaulle je ne
suis pas dupe mais enfin c'est un
hommage institutionnel qui me paraît la
moindre des choses
compte tenu des services éminents que le
général de gaulle a rendu à la france
pour le reste moi je ne suis pas je ne
suis pas le porter de la vraie croix de
lorraine
j'ai ma conception du gaullisme c'est à
dire tout le monde peut venir tandis que
le mans mais tout le monde ce soir en
été de tout du christ de bouddha de
napoléon de 14
moi je ne me retrouve pas forcément dans
les leçons que chacun de ceux qui se
réclament du général de gaulle tir de de
cette histoire car le gaullisme c'est
une histoire c'est pas une doctrine
c'est pas un catéchisme c'est une
histoire qui commence en gros le 18 juin
qui s'achève avec un vendu avec un mort
du général de gaulle d'ailleurs le
général de gaulle à part ces ouvrages
sur l'armée dans l'entre-deux-guerres
n'a écrit que des mémoires
le mob aux listes chienlit revient
beaucoup dans la bouche de certains de
vos amis en ce moment vous l'avez
constaté qui a raison dans le nouveau
bras de fer qui est pas encore réglé là
à l'heure où on parle entre le
gouvernement et les syndicats sur cette
fameuse manifestation de jeudi à paris
les syndicats refusent catégoriquement
une manifestation statique alors
d'apprenants lequel d'abord de la
manifestation statique une manifestation
statique c'est plus dangereux qu'une
manifestait aucun défilé
voilà c'est moi j'ai fait l'expérience
de la manifestation statique lors du
débat sur le mariage pour tous
on a le gouvernement qui attendait moins
de monde a fait a interdit aux
manifestants de défiler il les a il a
interdit de traverser la place de
l'étoile
il a parqué sur l'avenue de la grande
armée et je peux vous dire que la
poussée de la foule qui s'entassent de
plus en plus est extrêmement dangereuse
et au demeurant d'ailleurs si des
violences devaient éclater au milieu de
cette foule
ça serait bien pire qu'au milieu d'un
défilé pour donc voilà je ne crois pas
du tout à la supériorité en matière de
sécurité delà de la manifestation
statique voilà pour le premier point
le deuxième c'est que le gouvernement
est responsable de l'ordre public
mais j'ai paris palais pas les syndicats
je ne comprends pas comment dans une
démocratie on peut interdire une
manifestation de salariés ou de
syndicats cela vous l'avez entendu les
arguments les connais vous avez
maintenant l'image des dernières
manifestations oui monsieur sécurité des
biens et des personnes et bien sûr des
soviets attaché derrière les violences
autour de la thématique des forces de
l'ordre mais mais la fatigue des forces
de l'ordre ne peut pas justifier qu'on
interdise des manifestations qui sont
l'expression même de la démocratie
moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec la cgt
suis pas non plus d'accord avec le medef
sur la la nuit avec le gouvernement mais
en fait contre le maire mais oui je suis
contre l ol va dans nos rues depuis le
début mais enfin c
il est quand même extravagant de penser
qu'un gouvernement peut faire cela alors
le gouvernement d'ailleurs s'est mis
dans une situation impossible et il
affaiblir une fois encore l'autorité de
l'état parce que imaginer que les
syndicats décident de placer des gens
même de manifester alors m il va t-il se
passer
que va-t-on faire que peut-on faire mais
quand quand le gouvernement prend une
décision il doit être certain de pouvoir
la mettre en oeuvre
sinon il perd la face
et il affaiblit l'autorité de l'état
bref l'heure pas seulement celle du
gouvernement celle de l'état en tant
qu'institution et là le pays ne peut pas
continuer de fonctionner avec un état
qui s'affaiblit tous les jours bon que
fera le gouvernement si les syndicats
décident de manifester quand même c'est
une vraie question est chargé il va
faire charger les syndicalistes par les
crs violemment et vous allez vous pensez
que ces images à la télévision vont
améliorer le climat social du pays où
sont imprimés politiques dont le
gouvernement joue avec le feu
le gouvernement joue avec l'autorité de
l'état le gouvernement a mis tout le
monde dans un dans une impasse
ils savaient très bien que la cgt était
affaibli il a essayé de là il a essayé
de l'affaiblir encore ça me rappelle en
95 un gouvernement cette fois ci de
droite qui voulait tuer faux bond à la
pâte ufo mais en revanche on a on a
transformé un septennat en semestre cet
écrit ça a été un tel désordre que à la
fin je vais vous parler d'alain juppé je
poste je parle de 95 à la rue p waouw le
gouvernement de l'époque à leur demande
l'époque vous étiez fois un gouvernement
c'est pas là pour rien c'est efficace
est pas là pour affaiblir un syndicat
c'est là pour que le pays fonctionne
c'est là pour discuter pourra négocier
pour essayer de trouver comment faire
est très difficile mais vous vous êtes
quand même très gaulliste social vous
êtes pour des réformes quand même lewin
économique et social mais pas n'importe
qu'elle veut dire quoi cette espèce de
light motiv sur la réforme la réforme la
réforme on vous dit jamais 2 quelles
réformes il s'agit on vous met debout ce
moment sur la table un texte puisque
vous êtes pour la réforme bien voilà une
réforme alors accepter la veine on peut
être pour la réforme mais pas pour
celle-là d'accord alors pour vous
comment ça a été fait oui on n'a pas dit
si on a discuté avec personne
on a mis ce texte qui était ni fait ni à
faire ce qu'ils corrigeront avec des
négociations avec ses fans et le cias et
du marchandage
on a fait le gouvernement a donné droit
aux revendications de la cfdt
et il a ignoré les autres et ils
savaient très bien il savait très bien
qu'en si prenante de cette façon il
allait provoquer des blocages bien mais
c'est pas tout ça n'est pas tout c'est
non seulement si on en croit les
enquêtes même s'il faut pas gouverner
que les enquêtes d'opinion on est parti
quand même à 80% de français dans les
enquêtes contre andorre 65 à 70% à
droite c'est vous dire comment ce projet
les chiffres les plus hauts des bus sur
le projet de loi c'est à dire c'était
bien c'était c'était c'était bien par
laurie mais non c'est
je trouve que c'est assez important
parce que c'est représentatif de l'art
de gouverner
on ne peut pas gouverner de cette
manière on ne peut pas gouverner non
plus un pays qui quitte aujourd'hui
tétanisés par le chômage de masse
tétanisés par la peur de l'avenir
comment gouverne un pays au milieu des
trente glorieuses
quand on gouverne un pays dans cet état
on prend des précautions on sait que la
société fragile et on donne pas le
sentiment aux gens qui ont un emploi que
c'est de leur faute si elle est partie
de la population n'a pas d'enfant vous
parlez surtout à vos amis politiques de
droite 1 le parlement dans la merde oui
mais c'est le gouvernement qui l'a fait
libérer vous contestez j'avais une
question pour marc daou j'étais content
de voir mes amis d'hier je voterai ce
projet de loi mais il va pas assez loin
au début et dire aujourd'hui je ne
voterai pas parce qu'alors il va
vraiment pas ses lois dont je vais vous
voyez qu'on va sortir la france de
l'ornière dans laquelle elle et ne
payant plus les heures supplémentaires
un peu plus cher à ceux qui travaillent
le plus et qui ont besoin de ce pouvoir
d'achat supplémentaire pour faire leurs
fins de mois et bien vraiment c'est ce
qu'on regarde pas l'économie de la même
façon et vous et moi on va pas refaire
oui on va pas refaire tout le débat sur
la halle au travail mais là il s'agit de
mesures qui seraient avalisée par des
référendums alric
oui je rappelle l'intervention des
gouvernements non seulement n'a pas la
majorité dans pluie mais il a même pas
la majorité au parlement
c'est beaucoup plus difficile à défendre
le syndicaliste dans la magistrature
c'est précisément pour que la
magistrature soit un peu plus
indépendants parce que l'indépendance
est pas juste l'indépendance d'avis du
pouvoir politique indépendant c'est
d'abord l'indépendance vis-à-vis de
soi-même vis-à-vis de saison de ses
engagements vis-à-vis de son idéologie
vis-à-vis de ses choix politiques faits
nous avons que les religieux donc le
syndicalisme est en train de détruire de
détruire l'objectivité l'impartialité de
la magistrature ça suffit je pense que
les syndics le syndicalisme n'a rien à
faire dans la magistrate donc vous
président vous interdire étage
moi je ne dors je ne soutiendrai pas un
candidat à la présidentielle si ce n'est
pas moi je ne soutiendrai pas un
candidat qui ne proposera pas une
réforme importante de la justice la
justice aujourd'hui est un élément du
désordre du chaos des institutions la
peau premièrement surtout le manque de
moyens dit on
non mais ça je suis d'accord il faut des
moyens le fusil mais attendez c'est pas
là on parle pas des moyens les moyens
nous renvoie à la politique budgétaire à
la politique économique
vous voulez devine que ça sorte non mais
je passe par quoi la priorité là il ya
pire qu'il ya d'abord on ne peut pas
donner de tels pouvoirs à des gens qui
n'ont de compte à rendre à personne
un principe de responsabilité doit être
établi instaurée et contador est de 6,6
à la justice et à la police
enfin l'état la police tôt vous pouvez
créer une autorité indépendante où il
n'ya pas de magistrats ou très peu voilà
cdm animations peuvent pas continuer à
se juger eux mêmes à se contrôler
eux-mêmes ainsi non protégés nord
mais sinon non pour l'instant c'est
plutôt beaucoup de citoyens qui doit
être protégé parfois des produits la
séparation des pouvoirs entre le poly
dans des injustices non mais là et ça ça
intervient principe de responsabilité
donc ça c'est normal quand on vous donne
le droit de détruire des vies sans
jamais avoir de comptes à rendre à
personne ça il est normal que ça soit le
seul corps ou quelqu'un qui commet une
erreur quelqu'un qui détruit la vie de
quelqu'un puisse continuer à être promu
c'est et à continuer à juger les autres
non ça c'est pas possible
le syndicalisme je vous explique ce que
j'en pense et il faut savoir quand même
que les militants syndicaux sont des
magistrats qui ensuite reviennent dans
la magistrature dans les formations de
jugement
moi je je ne peux pas comprendre ses
engagements politiques
un avocat pour vous dites engagement
politique se sont
c'est peut-être maintenant il ya les
deux on a vu en politique et
l'engagement corporates et dans les deux
cas
dans les deux cas c'est parfaitement
inacceptable mais politique
un avocat l'autre jour se rend à la cour
d'assises de metz le local de l'union
syndicale des magistrats
non madame et secrétaire général se
situe en face de la delà de la cour
d'assisses fin de la chambre assiste
bien et sur le sol sur la porte il ya un
dessin humoristique
alors saint palais de justice à son
tarif de certains déjà non c'est très
intéressant et ça sur des scènes
humoristiques ya nicolas sarkozy qui est
en train de tomber en glissant sur des
petits ronds et écrit il a glissé sur
les petits pois faisant référence à ce
que nicolas sarkozy avait pu dire dont
trois raisons la magistrature mais
c'était trop compliqué d'aller voir les
magistrats les dans un bras palais de
justice dans un palais de justice par
des magistrats qui vont revenir dans des
dans des formats de compte je voulais
aller duo syndical
c'est son nom je sais que j'en veux à
que principe de la deux du syndicat ni
dans la magistrature
voilà eh bien on proposera
l'interdiction et les français
trancheront à ckoi par un référendum sur
la justice moi je pense qu'il faut une
grande réforme réussie si un référendum
sur la justice en ce moment mais la
question c'est c'est intéressant comme
l'est jamais remplacer les juges des
tutelles pardon excusez moi mais est ce
que est ce que les journalistes ont un
petit peu travaillé la question du
référendum
le référendum ça n'est jamais est ce que
vous voulez pour les enfants ah oui
pardon mais on sur un projet de loi oui
sans projet de loi je casse par le vélo
car le chaos le camp anglais
il est il est tout à fait il est tout à
fait à part c'est ça veut dire 'est-ce
que vous rejetez tous les traités on
sort très bien la cc c'est une simple
question sans texte mais là plus qu'en
général le référendum c'est un texte
est-ce que vous approuvez la
constitution de la vème république
est-ce que vous approuvez des accords
d'evian seront proposés sur le riz c'est
toujours ça à un référendum
ça ça vous demande de vous prononcer sur
un projet de loi qui peut être un projet
de loi constitutionnelle ou un projet de
loi non constitutionnelle
voilà qui soit un projet de l'ordinaire
bon donc vous aurez si on le fait un
projet de réforme de la magistrature et
les gens seront amenés à dire oui ou non
à cette réforme
je ne sais pas vraiment c'est tout ça
pour répondre d'un débat donc la
responsabilité
le problème des centristes le problème
tant des les traits aujourd'hui elle est
vraiment à les menacer un dépenses
justice et 3e et troisièmement la
nomination il faut aller voir comment ça
se passe ailleurs mais les nominations
aux états unis elles sont faites par le
gouvernement américain pour les juges
fédéraux
les juges fédéraux la plupart des juifs
et des rites atouts sont ténus et les
autres sont nommés par le pouvoir peut
vraiment avec l'allemand en
grande-bretagne pays delà des mots clés
re-so de la démocratie une commission
indépendante le web et mobile une
commission indépendante nommée allemand
c'est pareil c'est nommé par la mise
mais pas émise la justice ou d'enfant
qui est un système très intéressant
une commission indépendante qui fait des
propositions aux milices la justice le
ministre la justice est libre de les
accepter ou pas signer refus ça revient
devant la commission qui refait d'autres
proposent un coeur bon alors ok on a
compris et c'est toujours
enfin la légitimité du pouvoir politique
elle est entière
c'est dans une démocratie c'est le
sait-il la souveraineté du peuple qui
s'exerce soit par la voie de ses enfants
entend donc en l'occurrence du
gouvernement et du parlement soient pas
en parlerez ferme a compris mais je ne
relancerait pas sur la notion et non
l'indépendance mais non mais parce que
l'indépendance dont il est question vous
faites référence est interne à la
constitution mais personne ne veut
remettre en cause l'indépendance de la
justice
mais elle n'est pas indépendante à
l'égard de la justice le pouvoir de
nomination
il est toujours politique toujours
politique dans une démocratie ou alors
on est plus en démocratie
les primaires vous en parler brièvement
tout à l'heure ça ne correspond pas à la
vème république elle marche sur la tête
la vème république avec un président
sortant qui sont de ceux là on marche
sur la tête tout court c'est toute la
vème république et marchal et tout le
monde marche sur la tête
d'abord les primaires elles ont un
inconvénient elle les enferme le
candidat à la présidentielle et le futur
président dans un camp c'est camp contre
camp alors première remarque les cas on
regroupe de moins en moins de gens c'est
à dire le ch qui regroupe aujourd'hui la
majorité des français c'est ccc de ne
pas appartenir un camp c'est il ya la
droite la gauche qui se réduisent de
plus en plus et puis à tous ceux qui
entre qui ne veulent plus de cette
histoire alors qu'il soit vivant dans
les partis protestataires soit quand
vous regardez là l'envolée des gens qui
déclarent que leur nom aucune proximité
partisane c'est considérable on voit
d'ailleurs sauf aux présidentielles on
voit d'ailleurs où on vote pour une
personne on voit d'ailleurs dans les
législatives ne sait pas les autres
ténors remontée delà de l'abstention
alors le fait que le président sortant
se livrent à ce jeu là la première
premier avec c'est la première oui c'est
la première remarque cette histoire de
caen est extraordinairement nocives
puisque le président de la république
aspirer doite aspire à devenir l'homme
de la nation et donc là dans l'état
actuel des choses les primaires c'est
une op à une confiscation de l'élection
présidentielle par les camps c'est à
dire en réalité pas parce qu'ils d
animer une structure les partis à droite
et à gauche mais bien sûr droite et à
gauche d'ailleurs ça a donné un résultat
merveilleux là on a fait des primaires à
gauche mais le pire président depuis le
début de la vème république qui juste
est un chef de parti qui enlaidissent et
se comporte comme un chef de parti
aujourd'hui en se livrant en acceptant
avec la primaire à gauche il se défend
encore plus la logique de parti mais
françois hollande d'un aveu de faiblesse
françois hollande cherche toujours la
petite combinaison qui va lui permettre
de se sauver il a été dix ans patron du
parti socialiste il a passé son temps à
ça et c'est sa vie c'est son savoir
faire part ça rien d'autre
mais ça a l'air de marcher parce qu'il
ya un premier sondage qui était publié
en mai sur instant et qui manquent
parmi les sympathisants de gauche ils
arrivent en tête devant les oreilles
d'abord le critère pour savoir si ça
marche c'est l'état du pays avant tout
autour de ta du pays vous fais pas un
dessin et imaginer qu'il soit réélu
demain
vous croyez vraiment que ça sera un
critère de succès mince car mes propres
amis ont dit de regarder
ils les ont fait des primaires est le
candidat des primaires a été élu ah oui
il faut voir ce qu on voit le résultat
pour moi le résultat c'est pas
l'élection le résultat c'est l'état du
pays en deux ans 5 4 en cinq ans après
je pars bruit on abaisse un peu plus
c'est pathétique on abaisse un peu plus
sa fonction présidentielle
c'est soi françois hollande considère
que les français n'en veulent plus
et il s'en va soit il considère qu il
encore une chance et il se présente il
est président de la république
imaginez déjà ces problématiques pour un
ancien président de la république c'est
à le renouveau de la démocratie même
pensé dans l'aude la démocratie non
c'est pas de la démocratie c'est la
démocratie c'est le peuple qui vote
c'est pas un petit morceau du peuple qui
essaient de confisquer l'élection pour
les 10 premiers ministres le ps est en
avance pour lui et bien sûr non
messieurs en avance
encore une fois on a vu d'ailleurs le
résultat c'est magnifique on a is an
ça a été la revanche de ce qu'il
appelait la vieillesse et philo sur le
sur le parti socialiste françois
mitterrand
les notables socialistes on aa notables
socialistes qui est chef de parti qui
est chef de camp c'est magnifique le
résultat est extraordinaire même son
canton mais plus pour ces c'est
extraordinaire parce que le sondage de
da c'est quand même que pour un
président sortant dans son propre camp
moins d'un tiers
moins d'un tiers de deux supporteurs
c'est quand même si même extraordinaire
comme comme résultat non c'est pas la
démocratie c'est le contraire de la
démocratie c'est une apparence de
démocratie qui confisque la démocratie
vous alliez dira juste quelque chose sur
nicolas sarkozy
non je dis sa présence y avait du monde
là rien ancien enchères venant de la
république
ils se trouvent obligés d'aller se
confronter avec ses anciens ministres
son ancien premier ministre un fonds
ancien plus pauvres sont enfermés moi je
fais pas campagne mais moi je fais pas
campagne contre nicolas sarkozy je
trouve cela très non la compétition et
weezer dans la compétition parce que je
peux pas rester les bras croisés d'un
système mais vous critiquez beaucoup
vous avez oui
un mitterrand a fait le plein de
paradoxes non c'est pas un paradoxe ça
s'appelle le dénommé critiques sur le
site dangereux chez moi dans ce match et
moi je vais d'ailleurs si ces primaires
sont verrouillés par les parties au
point qu'il n'est pas possible d'y
participer parce que le le système des
notables entre eux soit des notables est
tellement prégnant que il ya lui
paraissait impossible d'obtenir ce et
des parrainages de parlementaire et bien
et donc vous j'irais chercher dans toute
la france les 500 signatures d'élus qui
permettent de se présenter mais bien
celui d'une semaine que vous avez
annoncé votre candidature on vous avait
eu des soutiens thermique des parois
répondait conduire parrainage vous
répondrai pas à vous le saurez le moment
venu vous avez commencé votre chasse aux
individus ont déjà au moins
oui j'ai commencé par la chasse aux élus
locaux gt500